At this point what we have, is an unoptimized
version of the abstract behavioral spec. Implemented, ready to
run, but it is unoptimized. Remember that as component-based
design, there's going to be a lot of crap that
is going to be there in terms of the
interfaces between the components that have been assembled together.
To build the complex system. One word of caution
though, I mentioned that using IO automata is fantastic
from the point of view proving that, the
properties that we want in the original subsystem
is actually met by the behavior spec. That
is facilitated by the IO automata framework. But this
path that we took going from the abstract
to concrete behavior spec, to the implementation finally
ending up with unoptimized version. Which is executable
there is no guarantee that this an optimized version,
of code that we produced is actually meeting
this behavioral spec. Or in other words this
leg of design exercise proving properties. Of the
spec. That it meets what we set out for
the original subsystem, is in no way guaranteeing
that those properties are actually in the implementation. There's
no easy way to show that the OCAML
implementation is the same as the IO autometer specification.
This brings to mind a famous quote that is attributed
to Don Knuth. Many of you. We know him as
an expert in algorithm development. He's written several books on
it. And a quote that is attributed to him is beware
of bugs in the above quote. I've only proved it
connects, not tried it. [LAUGH] So in other words, he is,
he's and expert in developing algorithm but he's saying I
need convert the algorithm to code. There's no way to prove
that the code is actually, faithfully reproducing the
algorithm. That's sort of the same thing that is
going on here as well. That we have an
abstract behavioral spec. We can prove properties about the
behavioral spec, and we can convince that whatever
we set out for the subsystem is actually met,
in terms of the specification but there is no
way to prove. That this implementation is actually faithfully
reproducing the behavioral spec. This is the software
originating road map, for synthesizing a complex system
starting from the behavioral spec, all the way
to an un-optimized implementation of the system. So
those are the first two pieces of the
puzzle, namely specification. And then implementation. And the
third piece of the puzzle of course is
going from this unoptimized version to the optimized version.